photos this morning and I this is funny
but it's not funny is it yeah no she's
not funny now exactly central to bleezy
Georgia course flash floods burst open
azuz gates and allowed lions tigers
bears and wolves to escape but three
zookeepers were among at least 12 people
who died in floodwaters this
hippopotamus was seen in a city square
and later tranquilized by police and
moved back to the zoo helicopters are
flying over the city to find missing
animals and officials warn residents to
stay in their homes blue oh yeah hard to
stay in your home but at the same time
you don't want to get hurt in Singapore
people dress up in pink during the pink
dot rally at Hong Lim Park the lights
from the parade were visible at night
the braid is Singapore's annual rally to
support the freedom to love regardless
of sexual orientation or gender identity
Singapore has been envelope in
controversy over its approach to
same-sex relationships with an all-out
ban on them so that's a big deal of
great picture before embracing same-sex
relationships number one in our top
photos today to mark the 800th
anniversary of Magna Carta the British
Library in London is holding a special
exhibition it's the ceiling of the Magna
Carta anniversary since 1215 the Magna
Carta has become an international symbol
of individual rights it means great
charter is the charge of the King John
England issued recognizing person he
attended the Council on Foreign
Relations richard has introduced oh no
but I want to tell you one thing as part
of the celebrations there's a barge the
Queen's barge floating down the Thames
it's called Gloriana ok there is amazing
it was lady 1515 oarsmen sort of just
gently hanging it up the Thames oh there
you go getting sailboat cigna that is
not a sailboat there isn't it a sailboat
is not or propelled these are
distinctions that are not lost on the
layman